hey guys
it's alana again the audio sucks for the
first minute and a half because
austin forgot to press play on his mic
and troy still has a crackle i'm really
sorry
i would also like to point out
on this subject that this podcast has
seemingly captured austin in various
states of moving
it feels like and yet i'm going nowhere
yeah it's the box it's the piano just
moves ever so slightly just to see if
people are paying attention
and then there's a box on top of it and
then a ship
i do i wouldn't have brought it up if i
didn't this is a daunting oh my god
if did anybody else feel like that was
way bigger
[Laughter]
so this was hand carved
by my father when i when i was a kid
uh we had to do a book report and i
chose
voyage of the dawn treader from the
narnia chronicles that's my favorite
book
and i i was i was i was plowing my way
through the series at the time and then
i just kind of incidentally chose that
one
and we had to i can't remember the
specifics of the assignment this was
probably
third or fourth grade but i remember we
had
um um
the wait a minute
why is something happening here are you
trying to remember something what's
happening
i'm just looking around what does it
mean
i'm discovering a technical
technical audio list i discovered a
technical challenge
uh that i corrected i mean technical
challenge that's a nice thing
it's so smooth so smooth yep so
barely apologies on the uh audio you'll
be receiving up until the moment i
discovered that
um yep so uh
this was uh the book report stipulated i
guess that we just make something uh
related to the book you know i don't
remember
if it could be anything or whatever it
certainly would never have been
initially my idea to do this
but my dad was like oh let's carve
a dawn treader and then very quickly it
was like
look you're slowing me down here i need
to just make some progress on the thing
so my dad just full-on went and did the
thing completely cool
austin that's and this is exactly like
the south park episode of the pine
yeah pinewood derby oh yeah you've got
to see the date already
no it's not it's beautiful so
what happened was um i then found myself
with this dilemma where i'm like i'm
supposed to go to school in like the
fourth grade with this masterfully hand
i mean like can you see like the the
dad your dad was amazing he made he made
lifeboats that are separately
then glued on and then made a little
cloth sail and
so the funny thing was and the curved
tail that's solid like
the tail it it it um it's a solid piece
that's carved that way
so the hilarious thing is i then have to
go and essentially pass this off
as my work i did this overnight
and uh without the total help from my
dad now did you just use everything that
was in the kit there's nothing else yeah
exactly so i i i think there wasn't
a big blow back from it at school but
then the funny thing is that my
my dad then uh put it on a shelf in his
office labeled the shrine to bad
parenting
where it remained for uh
20 years or something until one day i
took it back and i said you know what i
want
that thing i i uh no that's super cool
where has it been i
i where where in your office has it been
it it it moves around
it it kind of it wasn't season stuff
yeah yeah exactly it's seen some
what a [ __ ] series that was yeah voyager
of the dawn title was my favorite in
that series simply because it was the
first time that they really
demonstrated consequences like not
everyone's coming back
like you know the first two they're
there language in the wardrobe they're
there
um and then the second one is uh um what
was it
uh was it prince caspian no i can't
remember the order that's later in the
series
it was twice was the second one because
that's when they they go and they
they free him and they get the animals
to fight everything voyage of the dawn
treader is the one where prince caspian
has grown up
it's been so long it's been so long
since i read them and i never watched
never never watched the movies i heard
that that's why it's what i heard yeah i
i loved that series yeah it was
but isn't there isn't there a thing
where the book or there's like a
publication order that's
separate it's kind of like final fantasy
in japan versus the us and the
interesting yeah because the series
jumps around a whole lot yeah well like
it
it moves away from edmund and lucy and
and peter
and susan so like after after dawn
treader
because it goes like silver chair and
all that stuff which which was a
completely different
i just swear i remember there i'm super
nerdy
to me again i was like there were kids
that like
they're gonna play this are you gonna
like it was either tolkien or it was
gonna be
uh c.s lewis and i just went c.s lewis
uh and i read tolkien
way later but like i know how kids read
tolkien like when i was a kid
hobbit is the first book that i actually
finished reading and then
that's not uncommon it's a lot but my
parents were like let's graduate you
just read lord of the rings and i
couldn't it was it was
too too heavy many adjectives i think
was like just so these people use a
different language
i can't i can't really i just didn't i
could if you want a really trippy thing
like cs lewis like
sure that that whole um chronicles of
narnia is is great
um it's definitely his homage to to
tolkien because they were friends
isn't narnia like the lion is
literally a parallel to god like it's
hyper religious
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no it's it's super it's way
more of a messianic character
lewis is an oft-quoted essentially
christian apologist like a lot of his
arguments are are referenced in like
debates and stuff
he is the apologist like the great
divorce
is is a is an amazing book but c.s lewis
c.s lewis was basically a um an
apologist without
being dogmatic he was just such a
logical pragmatist about it
and it his his his writing is incredible
but my favorite of his
even though i have such a nostalgia for
for chronicles of narnia
is actually the space trilogy that he
did where's the space trilogy
also just because it's happening
semi-frequently i wanted to apologize to
everyone for the crackle and choice
blaine elgato i love michelle it seems
to be a software problem you can hear it
now right austin
i heard it that time you know what it
sounds like it sounds like when you're
on the phone with someone who's got the
headphones with the mic attached to the
earbud and then rubbing on something
yeah grubs i'm not rubbing anything my
hands are up here
just so you know back to the space now
back to the space
so if you if you want to check it out
it's really dope um
the first one is out of a silent planet
which is also a great king's x record
um perilandria and that hideous strength
and the premise is this
a man named ransom which [ __ ]
awesomeness oh yeah hell yeah
is this a kojima production um
sam ransom he gets kidnapped and taken
aboard a spaceship
to mars and once he lands there he finds
this whole race of people and they're
discussing is like
tell us what it's like on your planet
he's like well we've got the system of
government
that looks like this they're like okay
and it's like we've got this system of
religion where we believe in god like
yeah we know god
like oh so you have like a similar that
was like no no we know god
and also on your planet is the evil one
like what oh yeah you got you have the
devil there but he's bound to earth he
can't leave so he we've never been able
to be here
and it's like being in the garden all
over again there's no knowledge of
of there's no notion of sin there's no
notion of right and wrong
there just is and then you find out that
the devil hijacked
on he was a stowaway under the spaceship
and he just goes through mars
and he starts rampaging across it and
just creating atrocities
and they come across like something that
was kind of never heard of this
yeah dude it's so dope they're like we
don't understand what happens like well
somebody killed this like i don't
understand
what happened it is such a cool like
cool premise but and then that is
literally called the space trilogy
otherwise called the cosmic trilogy the
cosmic trilogy
the last one working title paralympics
years later a young john romero pearl
andreas
shows but he was like he was doing some
drugs man that guy was like
he had been hanging with all those cats
that were like experimenting with
um masculine and everything else because
he he that that there's no way
there's no way he can write that [ __ ] in
a sober mind anyway a fragment of
another sequel was published as
the dark tower in the dark tower and
other stories
stephen king well it says the dark tower
but i imagine it's got to be a different
dark tower
it has to be oh yeah c.s lewis has a
a manuscript incompleted uh called the
dark tower
that is an unfinished sequel to the
science fiction novel out of the silent
planet
interesting that's super cool i had no
idea all i knew was narnia of course
he's written other things
yeah the great divorce is is a really
really good
um i don't know if it's what it's called
it's like it's unapologetic it's it's
it's his treatise on how [ __ ] up the
church is
hmm it's great so he's the one who's
very oh yeah cs lewis so he is religious
but you're calling him an apologist to
me
apologist always sounds like someone who
is not the thing but is apologizing on
behalf of the thing
it's the opposite the apologist is the
defender like a defender
a christian apologist would be someone
especially in the modern use of that it
would be like
who defends these christians yeah and
someone who can like
formally uh sort of debate a given
proposition like here
are like there's a very famous one named
william lane craig who quotes
from c.s lewis fairly regularly and he's
you know he's like got a
doctorate in you know philosophy and
religion and that kind of thing and
offers
very kind of intellectualized arguments
around
the you know things like the historicity
of jesus you know like what is the
actual um evidence that he even existed
first off and that all the things that
are written about in the bible
happened he's the kind of guy who the
apologist who goes in and argues and c.s
lewis's big contribution to that if i'm
remembering correctly
was he basically said you end up with
three possibilities with regard to jesus
that he was a lunatic essentially a
crazy person that convinced a bunch of
people
of his madness um um
or that he wasn't mad rather that he was
a liar deliberately decepting people or
that he is in fact the lord that was
like his little sort of l
trifecta um and what i like is that
there's a
modern modern philosophy uh counter to
that that says you're leaving off one
potential
fourth one at least one fourth one i
mean which you can also
which you can also well if you accept
the premise that he exists
okay got it then it's he's one of these
three things there's the fourth one
um which i like because it's still an l
would be a legend the idea that
it wasn't editorialized right that's the
other one yeah
exactly like people people transmitted
the story and it changed a little bit
each time
until it wasn't what he himself would
even have does anyone read the name of
the wind
patrick no okay so you're the are you
the are you the person that keeps
that the one with jesus and christ has
separated characters is that one
no however um it kind of touches on
these themes
uh still waiting for the last book to
come out it's been waiting for a while
on that not not as bad as
game of thrones fans but uh it's very
much about
a guy who is seen as being this absolute
legend who's like known for
you know calling lightning um and and
it's like it starts in him
retelling a story but from his
perspective everything is
sort of sometimes an accident or a
little bit of a fluke uh so it's like
taking a fantasy novel
of some guy who has done all these grand
things in his life but from his
perspective
a lot of it is just very basic he's
still pretty impressive but a lot of
it's like i didn't mean to call the
lightning it just kind of happened
like that was not a thing that i planned
as some kind of god um just beautifully
written though there's this phrase that
rothfuss uses all the time but for some
reason i really love which is when
two characters are walking next to each
other he will say they fell into step
that's just such a poetic way to phrase
that like i always really
just love the way that he writes he'll
describe like a sky in a way that i'm
just like damn dude
it's all paul play with each other
and they lay with each other now
one one final comment on this and we can
probably get back on the topic but i i
never even touched on them we were never
on the topic yeah no they were talking
about books
you know alana is going to cuddle yeah
all of this is getting cut
most people don't realize that
everything that we
accept as as fact as quote
a fact or history about jesus was at one
time
voted on and it was by by committee
over the course of two different things
as the council of nicea and the council
of trent
where the churches that existed in its
time
was just like it again there's a south
park reference for this is like
everybody believes in all these
different things
and the first thing they had to vote on
was like okay hands up
was he god or was he not and they were
like the and the eyes got it
but they were definitely like we had to
count and see it wasn't this unanimous
vote there were people like
he never said he was god he was like and
there are absolutely said he was god
there are books of the bible isn't he
not god isn't he the son of god
depends on if you're a trinitarian
depends on the theologist
so this this is this gets into it i did
go to a religious school so that's
probably just like what i've learned is
like they never
they obviously never teach you the other
side this is this is the incarnation no
it's it's more poetic than that it's the
idea that he is
he is a manifestation so you've got the
he is also jesus christ the holy ghost
and the trinity would be father son holy
ghost right
in nominations they are all the same
being in theory
according to some theologists and not
others which is a responsibility a lot
of time to debate and discuss yeah
yeah which which is a response to other
cultures we're like wait a minute you
have one god
because think about most most religions
that that especially at that time
or since you know in early uh history
were a multi-theistic society
so that's one of the arguments for how
you know
a lot of um christian theology
well all religions really are are kind
of on the backs of whatever
whatever came before them and there's a
lot of sort of repurposed mythology and
symbols and
one of the things that i think people
and especially the more
devout you are the more this may make
you uncomfortable but like
the thing that is interesting is that um
um this notion of of monotheism
is clearly kind of being sold uh through
the ten command
well the first commandments where quite
literally the first
is put no god before me right um and and
i think that
arguably gets spun as a like have no
sort of false idols um but in reality
it's like you look at
the roman context in which this is
emerging and it's like
you know those gods are fine
mine's better
sorry the old the the ten commandments
are
from uh i'm sorry not not free you're
right it's not
it's not rome it's pre pre pre sorry
apologies like
no no you're right you're right i see
comments i close my eyes and i see
comments
it would be competing with more
babylonian um
yeah but the same they say applies like
i'm not yeah
the the thing about it is and before
this again i'm looking at the comments
too
um it doesn't it doesn't change
anything it doesn't change the poetry of
it it doesn't change
not at all once you understand that
genesis was literally a poem
and it was this metaphor in this
beautiful allegory to explain to people
something
to help assuage fear it doesn't change
anything and that's that's the thing
that i've never been able to understand
of why people whenever people get
dogmatic and they stop sinking answers
or
as my dear comrade austin would say stop
seeking the question
then you're you're steeped and you can
only go so far
dogma can only go so far and what i i
believe far more
so easily undermined anyway yeah it's
like they're super the answer
i mean to your point about voting on
what's considered canonical in the bible
or not there were literally
many centuries where whole books
uh and gospels that are now considered
forgeries or you know apocryphal like
they were they were considered part of
the core text for century there were
whole many generations of christians
that had a very different bible
um that we have a little even little
catholics have a different bible than
like the protestant or
you know other fundamental faiths but
there's there weren't four dudes that
wrote
gospels there were there were gospels
everybody was like well i'm gonna tell
you my story
and the funniest one is that john the
apostle john was the last one to write
it
and the way he starts he was like i was
the one he loved
because he knew that nobody else could
argue with him it was like we're all
desperate you can't i could
he i was his favorite because nobody
else could be like
he hated you what are you talking about
what i love from my perspective there's
austin and i on the top and then mike
and alan
on the bottom and austin are just going
nerd back and forth about
history and philosophy and michael are
just
i thought the scope of this show had
peaked i thought we'd kind of found the
outer limits of where we could go
nope i don't know today we suppress
we're solving religion
well
[Laughter]
and i was gonna ask you but now i'm
afraid because you know it's
we're 20 minutes in and we've spoken
about religion most of the time but it's
a video game podcast quote unquote
i was going to be like well i know that
uh mike i think it was your dad as a
programmer
austin what does your dad do he was an
orthopedic surgeon
completely unrelated to quite different
to composing
oh yeah yeah his mother was a musician
but
my favorite is definitely a skeleton
piano joke that i couldn't get to in
time
tickling the ivories no it doesn't work
um
my my father has always had these are
made from human remains
yeah it feels like that thing is so much
further from you and when you reach it
it makes it feel even more efficient
it's the fisheye lens if i
if i tilt back i look especially
flattering wow
it's beautiful it's a good one dad is a
building manager right now he's worked
in like construction a lot
very like handyman stuff but he also
writes books all the time in his spare
time really cool yeah and like one of
the coolest things that he has ever done
is he's been
uh working on this like horror novel uh
where just out of nowhere being a
60-plus year old
white man in australia made his
protagonist an aboriginal girl
and i was like [ __ ] yeah dad what the
hell just like out of nowhere it was
like yeah so it's like this horror
series about
you know people mistreating nature and
then the animals get reincarnated and
come back to life and
start basically that was our turn [ __ ]
yeah
that's so cool is uh giovanni rabizi the
bad guy
yes yes has ever been published
technically this
the spirit of the world no which is an
interesting one because um
i've also written my whole life and
never cared about being published and i
wonder if that's just like
directly inherited from dad because like
he'll write it uh he wrote a kid's book
that like my sister and i got to enjoy
when we were kids it had like songs
alongside it um that he called razzie b
was about a bee and like how bees you
know pollinate and help the earth
um so i had this experience of having
this kid's book that like he even had an
artist like draw all the pages but he
never published so there's like this
kid's book that is unique to my
childhood holy grail and my sister has
it too that i could still sing you the
songs
but they don't exist to anyone else it's
just for my sister and i
is there no ambition to get this out
there this seems like it
needs to be he probably could publish
that one like again
like he had art made but i like i feel
the exact same way i've written a bunch
of stuff
and have never cared about publishing
any of it we'll send it to my friends i
don't why do i
why like i'm just i know that i should
in theory
but in my head i'm like i'll just have
my friends read it like i don't
care about it like everyone else reading
it like i just have no
i think it's cool i think it's a hobby
really i think it's cool
my favorite book you don't have to
monetize your hobby like you don't have
to work
out a way to turn a hobby into a
business me austin and troy and you do
but like it's nice to have little things
there so this is what it is
it's not even about the monetization of
it look my favorite book ever was never
meant to be read by anybody else it was
the private journal of a man
but i i i guess for me it's like man i'm
really proud of this
i want people to hear it it has nothing
to do with but like that song that we
did because
plus it could be published for free so
yeah so what i'm thinking about doing is
one of them that i've been thinking
about
that i would maybe publish it and have
all revenue go to charity or something
that would be the way to get me to
publish something but otherwise i'm like
i just don't care about
people i don't know reading it do you
want to be vocationally a writer
well i am okay yeah so i guess my thing
is like
that they're like i i want to direct
more and nobody wants to be
the one who goes all right we're gonna
give you your first movie or you're
gonna first game or whatever so i mean i
i did a game but then i'm immediately
strapped to the success or the failure
of of that
so people were like i even said i was
going to do a short and i had a dear
friend of mine who's
a director he said don't do a short that
doesn't prove anything just because you
directed that he's like
whatever you can shoot in two to three
days doesn't demonstrate
how you will deal with invariably the
obstacles that happen over the course of
or whether you're worth a massive
financial bet
hey i feel like sure the directing side
of the industry i don't know that i i
don't know that i agree with that
um i mean i i i i director of yours is
just gonna have
yeah well that because that's that's
pretty much what i was going to say is
is you in trade
are um um
showcasing your creative capability
and if that's really heavily on display
like
remember the um the portal like fan film
yeah um um do you remember who directed
that
um it was dan trachtenberg um
it was the guy yeah the guy who i'm
pretty sh certain off of the back of
that
to make 10 cloverfield lane and that was
a short film because it showed
talent and vision similar cases wes ball
he made this um short film he was a
visual effects
guy and was running a visual effects
company and decided to kind of
essentially make the equivalent of a
demo reel except it was his own creation
it wasn't a highlights reel of past gigs
and he made this short and he got all
these meetings
to potentially option it as a feature
and then
one of those conversations that the
folks at fox said
why don't you read this book and instead
of us make your short into a feature
why don't you pitch us how you would
make this book into a feature and he
went and read it and
and then ended up directing the three
maze runner movies instead
uh so like i think what i'm trying to
to basically you're wrong is
there's directing which is i i have a
vision for this and i can
conceptualize this and and show you that
this is the approach that i would take
to this thing
and then there is directing
because directing is uh
the the great quote from from tim miller
he was like 80
of directing his meetings yeah and every
once in a while i get to go to set
and he said i have to have um i don't
think he's telling tells out of school
but
uh ryan reynolds they first get to the
apartment in deadpool
and ryan reynolds is just freaking out
he's like look at this place this is
incredible tim
did you know this is gonna look like
this he goes i had
five meetings about that bookshelf about
every he goes
he's like a captain on a ship he knew
every screw that was on that so
that's not necessary and not only that
the reason there were five meetings
is because he had to capitulate
and sacrifice and compromise on every
little item that was going to be on the
shelf it's like i want to be
would it be cool if a little r2d2 well
that's
that's fox that's not disney so we can't
incorporate that so i understand that
marvel had
so there's all these little things that
has nothing to do with i did a short
that i wrote and directed and shot
myself
versus here's all of the team of people
that i need to assimilate
and and accumulate in order to execute
this vision
so that's why he was saying don't waste
money or
even time doing a short because that's
not really going to demonstrate what
it's like to do a feature much less a
game like two and a half years of
development or 18 months of development
oh my gosh how many meetings do you have
to have and how many kids
even in games though like i have like i
definitely
someone someone asked me on twitter the
other day if i wanted to direct a triple
a game
i'm like it doesn't matter if i want to
direct a triple a game i
i wouldn't give me that budget that's it
the team wouldn't trust me right because
you're going in as someone who's
got no experience of that scale of
production it's a very different thing
so i think there's a i think it's even
within games even within film i imagine
it's hard if you're someone who's
directed
a bunch of i don't know romantic
comedies to go
and pitch an epic um disaster movie
right just
for completely different scales of
production so
yeah you're always going to pitch the
best advice i ever had was just
make the thing you want to make and
eventually people will show up who want
to pay you to do the thing
and even if you're making it bad and
that's there's actually loads of
examples in film of this right the um
what's the guy who directed monsters
called who went on he directed um
uh rogue rogue one i think didn't he
gareth everybody did
gareth edwards yeah so gareth edwards
his his breakout was monsters which i
think itself was actually based on a
short film
which was have you heard of monsters
this is a great movie to go and see
definitely worth like a rental
especially with the context i'm about to
give you so it's basically
it's a movie the premise of it is
there's you know kaiju they're like big
octopus monsters
and but they're contained in a specific
area and
it's they're kind of they're they're
contained and held down but their
uh people are trying to get out there's
people trying to escape the area these
monsters are in and get out of that
space and into america and into europe
so what they did was they they shot this
and then the story follows a couple of
tourists who get caught up in
all of this so they shot it on borders
of countries where they were immigrate
where there were immigrants trying to
get across where they were
all these deprived areas and they just
essentially you literally gareth edwards
did the visual effects on the laptop in
after effects he just add like signage
saying
quarantine zone you know monsters that
way
and you completely buy it when you're
watching the film if you go back and
watch it you're like
and it actually makes the film actually
in retrospect kind of awful as well to
an extent because all the extras are
actually people who are in a bad
situation and trying to work their way
through
but it's such a kind of good way of
making essentially a massive budget
movie it looks
it looks like a big budget kind of
disaster movie
but it's not it's just it's just you
know what would you guess the budget
interesting i just looked it up uh
because i haven't seen this i i never
heard of gareth edwards before he made
the
2014 godzilla film um um
oh that's right i really enjoyed that
actually that was that was what i think
probably
came out of this one it's really
interesting
amazing too though like like neil blanc
i was like watch what
he was short so he did short movies yeah
but look like somebody said you can make
he goes i did this for
you know for nothing i did this a badass
special effect for nothing i think the
same thing for tim miller too timler's
own blur for for years and they did all
of the video game trailers he's like i
can make this look
awesome and i i think that without the
success of james gunn which is like
looks what look what happens when we put
something nerdy in the hands of a true
fan with true skill and talent
as opposed to let's get the big big
director
let's get someone who really really
cares about this and tim miller just
made deadpool
one of the greatest marvel movies in my
opinion period so good
what would you guess the budget of
monsters
i know the answer to this one because i
used 110 billion
that's the thing that's astonishing
because there's low budget and then
there's this
half a million dollars primer oh well so
it's not primer
oh yeah that's pretty nuts watch
monsters it looks like it cost 50
million at least
no [ __ ] it looks like an expensive movie
it's really it's really interesting and
if you know the context of its
production
um and it was it was basically as far as
known as the director and basically it's
you've got two
two leads who are going through the
scene they would literally walk up to
people and ask them to play like
supporting roles
it's basically a documentary but with
this layer of
fictionalized kind of context around it
it's really dude i'd give them i'd give
that guy a movie
if he could do if he could turn i mean
what did he do well they gave him
godzilla that was that was his pitch for
godzilla essentially it was look what i
did with half a million
now give me godzilla to your point
about like the don't make the short film
i would disagree with that
i also made a short film this month i
haven't edited it yet though uh
but i would say for anyone who like ever
wants to thank you
you're invested in your disagreement for
anyone who ever wants to get into my
field
where it comes to games media i i'm
always going to say
just start making stuff like i don't
know what it is
like how much you get published like it
doesn't matter to me if you're doing it
for someone else or if it's a youtube
channel that nobody watches i don't care
just get the experience in any capacity
that you can to just start making stuff
so whenever anyone's like how do i get
my start
like you just start it doesn't matter if
your start is bad don't worry about
failing when you start
my early videos are still on the
internet and they're terrible and i do
have all of my archives of the first
stuff that i wrote and it's atrocious
but uh you just gotta you just gotta do
it yeah
the addendum to that what i would from
for my comment would be this
i would not make a short film expecting
that to be my calling card
to to direct yeah that's fair um i i
think that
olin rogers is a friend and a vicious
creator because he's just
whatever he has at his disposal he's
going to start creating stuff with it
and he's done everything from like a
camcorder
to an iphone to whatever he has he's
just i just got to create
and i believe if you want to create
then use the turn everybody has an
iphone or an android or something that
is a
wicked amazing resource for doing full
production
so i think that there's no excuse
technology can't be an excuse for you
not to make something
so i believe in just like write every
day shoot every day
make music every day do do something
every day
to help sharpen your skills but don't
necessarily think that that is going to
be the thing that's going to get you
that that can be the reason why you do
doing it for yourself education you
could be making youtube videos for 10
years and expect to get a job at ign
because you've made 10 years worth of
youtube videos it's not going to happen
that way like that that isn't how it
works but it's still better for you to
have the experience even on your own
than to not have any experience at all
just start making
the thing the topic starts
i know i know it was like we even get on
the topic because i literally might even
pinpoint it myself hi everyone because i
haven't introduced the show with 35
minutes in
welcome i'm
do you have your coffee today buddy i
have my coffee and well like always it
like the same amount troy the thing that
gets me is we drink them to the same
extent i
so i actually been speaking to an
audience weirdos tell everyone at the
same time wait let me intro all of you
first
i'm joined by austin wintery video game
composer troy baker video game actor and
mike
bithell video game director um i've been
speaking to an artist about getting us
a t-shirt and i've specifically tried to
get
a hand holding a coffee cup and then the
coffee cup's gonna say play watch listen
on it
i don't know i just i thought it was
cute so i'm trying to slowly work on
that that i thought was very cute but
obviously i'll send you guys like
emotions
i just after 28 episodes or whatever i
finally was like oh
i have this coaster that i could set
because before
this thing would like by the end of it
it was just like i would have this water
pool of condensation on my desk that
drove me crazy
and i was like oh i've got this really
cool august 2020 everybody troy baker
finally discovered coasters
have you guys have you guys seen this
what i love about your trichosis
my favorite is related to that one of
one of the recurring
troy motifs is already
the lean the lean off of camera and then
the like
of stirring the uh the setting
um uh you know the the what do you call
that i'm blanking
like the layering of your coffee how it
how it all like settles
yeah um
it's better than whatever the [ __ ] is
microphone's doing right now so
again no you're actually i mean it is
ever the start of every time you talk
but it didn't actually happen it's the
start of every time i talk
didn't happen that time but generally
yes yes it is
it's fine generally yes uh
so today wow 37 minutes
um it's fine i don't feel like we need
that much to dig into you know we're
gonna talk about everything that's been
going on with
apple and epic um and i think
xcloud is also tied into this entire
situation where
wait what is f cloud x cloud
oh x cloud i think it's an f cloud i was
like wait a minute
no not f cloud uh what is that sounds
great sounds great
um i can't i can't even think of a joke
for what f cloud no it sounds like it
was like
numbers
i think it was the first version of his
like i had the idea first but i called
it f clown they're like no no no that
doesn't make sense
ridiculous you're the wink winklevoss of
xcloud is what you're saying
we got to appeal to those kids with
their monster energy and you know
f cloud will never pull that out doritos
all that stuff
so to give a nice synopsis 40 minutes
into the show
uh apple has an app store war against
developers
and its ongoing anti-trust issues appear
to be coming to a head according to vox
um i would guess that most people have
heard about this but basically
fortnite is suing apple claiming that
its absolute practices violate the
sherman act
uh epic says that apple's requirement
that all mobile apps come through its
app store and the 30 cent
30 commission apple charges for app
sales and in-app purchases is a monopoly
and that epic as well as its fellow
developers and their customers should
have
alternatives uh i feel like i
fundamentally disagree with their logic
there um
apple or epics epics because if you own
a platform and people are buying into a
platform wouldn't it not be
a monopoly and they also don't have the
thing the market share
yeah apple apple is only gatekeeping for
apple devices right that was the part
that for me
it all i'm no legal scholar certainly
but it seemed like a stretch because
there are other ways to play the game
that don't have this
issue plenty right yeah um i mean the 30
commission thing is epic's been really
interesting about this you know like
people and still are very negative about
the epic game store
but i believe the epic game store the
cut for developers is
14 sorry for epic is 14
17 i thought it was less let me just go
and check a receipt
whatever i thought it was less i thought
it was closer i think it's is it 14 or
15
it's somewhere around there isn't it i
feel like it's definitely embarrassing
as someone who sells a game on the epic
story
but it's definitely the most it for sure
is the most
developer friendly oh yeah yeah oh
massively yeah
and and it's it's an interesting one you
know seeing people be so negative about
any game that's going to that platform i
feel like a part of that
oh yeah it's 12 by the way
it's so it's so good for devs and i
think you know again people are
very negative still very very negative
about people going to the epic game
store there's this whole thing with uh
ublets that i only recently found out
about
is like this just massive negative
backlash if you're going on the epic
game store because it's seen as
exclusivity even though you know there's
a steam loyalty which is still just
exclusivity in a lot of cases but but
there's no buy-in it's not like you have
to buy a membership to the epic game
store or something that's the part to me
that is so bizarre like
where are you which icon you click on to
become comments it's going to be so
great today i don't understand across
the board just all terrible
the bible or it's inconvenient
uh the epic games launcher
has its issues like i'm not totally
happy with that platform
um but the thing that i i keep thinking
about is when it comes to the 12 percent
you know a part of this that i feel like
a lot of people is missing uh is that if
you're
developers of making games and they get
the 18
more than they would for selling their
game on steam that money can help them
make more games
so it's it's not just like oh they get
more money it's no we all benefit from
this because
if you're buying the game yeah they have
and i think they're also pretty heavily
investing into a lot of people
um it's certainly helpful for uh for
control
uh because they launched on epic and i
pretty sure got a bunch of money for
that
well i also just have our last week's
specifics but we're all we were also an
epic store
exclusive on john wick which was was
very nice
sam sam same with super giant their
their first year of early access
on hades was epic exclusive and only
last december
became available on both for what it's
worth
yeah i agree with you to me the store is
not as elegantly designed as steam
although steam has many to me steem is
like
a software engineer's um store page and
there's so much about it that is
bizarrely technical and not user
friendly um
but it's still very clear and it's and
it's you know got a lot going for it
never mind just the sheer volume of
content and stuff but
to me it's like at the end of the day
when i'm playing the game
the instant i click launch the store
that it's launching from
means nothing and so i've never
understood the weird tribal it's very
different than
i i don't even really understand the
whole xbox versus playstation
uh sort of console wars thing but at
least that you
understand that you're making a
multi-hundred dollar investment
and it's going to come with different
exclusives and like i can empathize with
the people that get all wrapped
up into that that was also a literal
marketing thing like well that's
marketed to have console loyalty for it
to be a part of their identity to like
stick to it like that's like years and
years of marketing this has made
the console awards like a passionate
thing that look i i don't
i don't know entirely why people hate
the epic game store so i don't want to
say that i like it's ridiculous or i
don't understand it because i've
actually not
looked into it so like even points i
disagree with i generally want to be
like
what is their perspective but i
unfortunately just don't know this
perspective
but i also want to make sure that when
you say people hate it it's like
they're it is a is a widely accepted
across the board
everybody hates it or it's like no i've
just seen some bad comments about it
it's pretty like death ready aggressive
when people announce epic
game store exclusivity the same thing
about the last of us part two but it's
still the third highest selling
playstation exclusive game ever
yeah like yesterday well
yeah wait are you are you joel
wait who's bro are you are you oh boy
i'm certainly generalizing but i feel
like this is a
but it's okay if it's generally true i
just didn't know if i don't know about
generally true it's like impossible to
quantify on the internet but i would say
it is
there's a large there's a large backlash
that's fair the accepted
viewpoint is what i would say is that
like for me to say everyone hates the
epic game store i feel like people would
be like
sure like mike you must have yeah i mean
to that
mike you must have when when when uh hex
was announced
as an epic exclusive you must have
gotten tweets and stuff from people that
are like oh i would have bought it but
blah blah blah
or did you i mean we you do you do
anything you're gonna get
do you do anything involving video games
you're going to get someone tell you on
the internet they don't like what you
did
um but no we we were actually genuinely
like i'm and this
is not discounting i know that as long
as i said there's been lots of very
horrible reactions
we didn't get much i think because we
were very straightforward where they
were very
specific i think the other thing that
helped us was we hadn't already
announced we announced
as an exclusive so there was no one who
had gotten excited about it
being a steam game and then being
annoyed that we changed yeah i know it's
the biggest thing they're kind of
unusual because they had backers
and of course they were criticized for
being pretty sassy in the way they
announced it like that's complicated but
they still were getting
you know death threats for it um yeah
which is absolutely unacceptable and
but yeah
you know what i mean like there's
there's just the military not not
ninety percent of people gave death
threats it's like if if
i mean i just published a video about
ooblets i did a sponsored video on iblis
this week and that was a thing that like
anytime that anyone approaches me with a
sponsored video
uh when it's a game that i've already
played and like i'm like great like of
course i would do that and i
really like ooblets i had no idea any of
that had happened until reading the
comments on my video where people were
like did you not know about this and i
was like i had no [ __ ] idea
but it was i don't know it's a lot of
comments like a lot of people talking
about
hating ooblets for the way that it
responded to the okay
so it's a safe thing to say that this
one game received a lot of backlash for
being exclusive but you can't say that
everybody hates the other story
it's i still think i can i you know i
can tell you
again of course that is a generalization
but i i still
i would say among the games community at
large
people hate the epic game store like i
feel like i can say that
it's a we'll say say whatever you want i
just i i want to make sure that we're
not
perpetuating an unfounded statement that
no i think i think your point is a good
one
troy i but i think alana's right in
terms of like thumb on the pulse of the
kind of
general feeling of people i i would say
it's a
small but vocal minority which is often
the case right probably
um but they but they are it's
non-trivial
when pathless was first announced at um
the game awards a couple years ago
it was also announced as an epic score
epic store
exclusive and if you go and look at the
comments
there's always you know you don't have
to scroll every few comments there's
another one that's like oh man i would
have loved to have played this but [ __ ]
epic
you know yeah and it's like a lot of
negatives
yeah it's a strange i don't think that i
haven't done it certainly
but the reason that i wanted to bring
that up in general is um
that at the very least where epic is
coming from and like criticizing the 30
commission that apple charges they are
at least a company who
is coming from a perspective of doing 12
and not 30
like everyone else like they at least
have that leg to stand on
um and and for them to drive it makes
sense it's also part of the wording
if this works which it won't uh i feel
like
they've they've specifically phrased it
with the intention of of
protecting a lot of developers it would
set a precedent for these pro
these practices are predatory against
the development community um
in some of that that legal phrasing so
that would in theory
start to protect devs uh however
if you look at the it's so fascinating
like the companies who who
the ranking of global market share for
video games is number one
tencent which is epic by far number two
is apple and then number three is sony
unless i'm swapping
uh two and three i might be but uh it
they they are all top three and it's
like these are just like
mega corporations fighting over a month
so it's worth clarifying i don't think
10 cent a majority shareholders of epic
right like
it's not fair to say that epic is a ten
cent company i think you're right
i think the majority is elsewhere it's a
lot of congestion
look it up um no i think you're right
since then have a look
they have a lot of investments across
the i mean there's very few games
companies that you've heard of that
don't have some level of tension
oh that's that majority yeah so it's
sorry it actually says 10 acquired
approximately 48.8
of epic then issued share capital
equating to 40 total of epic so i think
that
they yeah that's pretty [ __ ]
significant that is significant but it's
not very secure yeah
yeah but it also i don't control as a
tangent off of that when
when the whole um trump uh banning
tick-tock and banning uh
tencent related uh commerce in the us
that immediately also opened up this
question of like
because i have a friend who works for
tencent who was like he wrote on
facebook
you know i love days when the president
is trying to make my job
disappear or something like that because
he's he's literally like one of the
american kind of liaisons to
10 cents um work here
and um and it's like the fact that this
happened in the same period of time
well is is that coincidental not to get
too speculative but i mean
mr conjecture over here i'm not even
yeah i was just saying like
i'm offering speculation though i'm not
i'm not passing it off as fast
as it is i'm wondering if that that
happens to be
because that does seem kind of like a uh
shots fired across each other's bowels
you know what i mean i think if you've
been paying attention to like
sorry and this now it sounds like i'm
insulting you for not paying attention
if we've been paying attention to
epic all this time i mean mr sweeney has
not been
private in his view the the these stores
should be more open
the percentages should be different he's
i think i saw a keynote at dice like
a couple of years ago where he was
talking about it's definitely been a
thing he's cared about for a very long
time
it might be that they've i guess they've
crossed they've crossed a threshold
where he feels
empowered enough to do it because
obviously fortnite has done so
phenomenally well
but yeah happened this is not a new
position
right they they announced a discount
for v bucks uh but the discount was
basically exploiting
a it's all like so
cyberpunky to me uh the discount was
exploiting like getting around
apple's 30 cut um so they were
for that exploitation however they did
it uh apple immediately took them off
the store
uh which is i mean it's the same reason
that xcloud isn't technically allowed is
that you would be able to purchase
things for xcloud that
wouldn't necessarily uh give apple a 30
cut which isn't allowed
um yeah the whole thing it also forces
their hand by doing that as an update
it um they they were they would have
been in breach
of the the license of the the whatever i
can't remember the exact wording they
would be
so it kind of forces apple to either
enforce their own rule
or the rule becomes irrelevant so it was
epic definitely forced apple into a
position where they had to ban them no
judgement morally either way but like
that was definitely the play was
correct to trigger at this event
again with the phrasing of this is
cheaper because we don't have to deal
with this big bad
uh company taking the revenue uh we're
literally announcing a sale and that's
what sparked this whole thing happening
was
well it'll be cheaper for you because
they're not stealing our money
that's how they kick off this whole
thing it's it's [ __ ] nuts so
uh i'll get back to what you were just
about to say austin but i did want to
get to
like the big part of this for me is
apple is now threatening to cut off
epic's access to its developer tools
program
that's basically what i was going to
bring up okay which would affect any app
that uses unreal uh and does any
consumers
use those apps yeah i always realized it
would be that far-reaching
that was the part that was the part
where it seemed like there's a lot of
potential collateral damage to people
that have
nothing to do with fortnite uh
especially for the partnership that
they've had from the very beginning
remember when they launched the ipad
they were like
unreal will run on the ipad they do that
with infinity blade
i didn't realize it would go that far
reaching
what well it has to is the issue is i
always just said the opposite i was like
i thought that they were just doing it
because
apple's like [ __ ] you i don't why would
it have to cut everyone off
so if so so the
so again like this is all speculation
but the issue here is
because i'm worried about troy
[Laughter]
go on mike no talking about the issue
obviously once you if you're making a
game in an engine you have the version
of the engine that exists
you install it you build the game you're
using those tools and your game
basically holds that code and uses that
code and interacts with the platform via
that code
so whenever i make a game i'm basically
building a
game layer on top of a big engine right
um i use unity but unreal it's the same
thing in that sense
um the issue here is no one's taking
away the version of unreal that a
developer
developer making an ios game right now
still has their version of unreal and
their version of unreal will work
and they can make stuff but the second
apple
changed something in in their software
in the
in the in the stuff we have to interface
with game as game developers so
interfaces screens features
any of that requires an update to the
engine
wow and if the engine can't be updated
because the company who makes the engine
is blocked out
everyone's stuck in the old version of
the engine so it's not that
they're blocking developers necessarily
from making games
but if you can't make if you if you
if the if this platform has moved on
involved a good example of this like
with that with any game we make for
console
um you you general generally it's not
best practice to keep upgrading your
engine while you're making a game
because it introduces a bunch of bugs
and issues
but generally the moments we really
usually have to upgrade our engine is
when we're doing say a port of a game
and we're like oh god xbox have added
this awesome new feature and we have to
support it so that means
we have to go our version of unity that
was released
a year ago doesn't have this it doesn't
plug into this feature properly
so we have to go and get the new version
of unity to plug it in it takes a little
while but we get it done it's fine
the issue here is yeah there's no more
updates in theory
this is all theory but like if this
drags on and unreal can't
support ios because they can't you know
run builds and
and which should interact with the
players they don't have to do this is a
retaliation
like uh i would think that right now
unity is just kind of going
what's gonna happen there who doesn't
have to do it who does that epic don't
have to do it no i'm saying you're
saying apple doesn't
apple doesn't have to do this i see this
as apple doing this as a just a
retaliation they're just like
they do have to well they have to
because when you're a developer on a
platform you
sign an agreement uh and again this is
all
legalese so like i'm sure lawyers who
are expensive enough could
plow through this but like when i when i
when i release a game on
let's carry on with xbox i sign a
contract with xbox that says okay mike
you can be on our platform but you can't
do this you can't do this you can't do
this you can't do this you can't do this
and in exchange we guarantee that if we
sell a copy of your game on xbox we're
going to send you your cards
so what you're saying is you have an
agreement epic would have signed a deal
that would be public everything to do
with unreal
epic will have signed a deal no epic
will have signed a deal
saying we won't push an update to our
game that monetizes outside of you so
why is that not just specific to
fortnight though yeah i was going to say
it to me it seems like because they're
the public so i think the ban would be
on
because the contract is not between
fortnight and apple the contract would
be between epic and apple
so therefore they're now a developer
who's broken the rules which means that
i guess the relationship wouldn't
continue
it just seems like to i think the
contract i think the point that alana is
making which is a similar confusion
fortnite's not a separate company it's
it's a thing major sure
but it still seems like two different
prongs of thought like right
because because epic epics
like store term violations seem
different from
unreal engines usability on
ios devices like that seems like those
would be
separate it's one it's what no because
they the engine
it's it's not the operability my
understanding is it's not the it's not
about the engine and banning the
engine's use
it's that the company that makes the
engine can't upload to ios anymore
so therefore can't build an engine that
works with that platform
wow that would be the difference that
that and again that's my stuff
okay so it does say apple will terminate
epic's inclusion in the apple developer
program a membership that's necessary to
distribute apps on the ios
if the company does not cure their
breaches to the agreement within two
weeks
so you would be right in there
it's just that they're in breach of
contracts and they would have to correct
yes epic is beings
but but this is still a retaliation it's
not fixed the thing in fortnight
where you you snuck in a new payment
option that
uh went around like it's not fixed
fortnight it's
i wonder if i wanted to know that's what
that would be is
is no the the the what you just read is
fixed fortnight and then it's all fine
by the way i'm not being an apple
apologist here i i have a good
relationship with epic but it's
definitely epic poke to the bear on
purpose you know for sure they did i
don't think that's
an animated video ready to go yeah but i
also don't know who's wrong in this
you know what i mean like clearly
neither do i is the weird part
and i also don't know what's gonna
happen like this is fascinating
wait i have so i have two i have two
questions for you mike related this is
better than game of thrones
[Laughter]
are now at war with the apples house
apple his father has waged
to me it's like kaiju fighting you know
it's just too
giant
but imagine this imagine if in game of
thrones
if the targaryens win your next project
makes x amount more money and if the
other side wins uh
then your game doesn't release it's like
game of thrones but with much higher
stakes to the game development community
which is why
that was the target apple's targaryens
right
it would make apple the bad guy
i don't know because i honestly from
what from what you just read
epic did it's like hey you if you didn't
agree with it that's fine
but it still lays out here these are the
terms and you guys went around the terms
epic puppets 100
around everyone being upset about xcloud
not being able to be on ios devices
is very convenient this is like a final
year like [ __ ] you apple you take that
so
i have to do it on audible if i want to
buy a an audio book i have to leave the
app on
the audible app and go to a web browser
on my phone and buy it through the web
browser because
yeah they can't do in-app purchases
exactly the same correct it sucks it's
annoying but the crucial thing is that
percentage split as well is an aspect of
this is
uh uphill do you know do you know where
30 comes from
there was no it was a negotiation with
the music and just it was a it was a
negotiation with the music industry back
in the day
oh yeah like 99 2000 itunes
it was it was how it was how they sold
itunes basically
to the thing was and that was the
percentages established
but it's not like in any way a number
that makes sense
arguably in the modern context but it's
safe to say that itunes established the
market value and everyone else in some
way or another phone
yeah all the other platforms have kind
of followed suit and 30 is kind of an
industry
if that 30 changed that would be massive
uh austin you said you had two questions
for mike yeah
so uh what is your birthday yeah exactly
oh you think why is the sky blue what is
your zodiac
orange um orange is my favorite color
scorpio
so um it's so two things when you talk
about
the the lack of updates for
apple support like the the kind of
communicability between the platform and
the engine right
whether because it seems like that could
go both ways if
unreal doesn't update and they are not
able to
connect with apple there's a question of
if the unreal update will
play nicely with the platform and then
also if the platform does some kind of
update on the ios
side that also so it seems like there's
a two-way traffic
problem there yeah well there's always a
relationship
so this is this is always my stock
answer to like you know when someone
says like are you going to make games
for playstation 5. it's like
i assume sony and uni unity have been
having meetings for a couple of years
and i presume the engine will work
like every yeah every platform holder
and every
uh major engine has a relationship
clearly this one is not in a good place
so all right so then yeah so unity
unreal and apple talk yeah
so then the the question that that's
essentially a preface to is
it does it actually prevent launch of
the game or does it just
increase the odds of bugs because you
are
operating on out-of-date uh
software basically like could i still if
i want to make a game today
that is in unreal engine and launches
and all this
follows through and just never update
yeah is it like
is it just like i'm potentially
releasing something broken or i just
can't
so most most platforms are backwards
compatible intentionally up to a point
so like
if you release if i release an xbox game
in if well i did so i know an xbox game
released in
2013 probably we released one in 2013.
you can still download and
play that game um and it will work and i
don't have to do an update to it i have
to like go back to unity and get the
engine that's fine
um on consoles that's true on pc of
course it's not true because windows
changes and then an old game doesn't
work anymore obviously everyone's aware
of that
same is true on like on android and
iphone is games
old games become unusable so no in the
short term
this would mean and you know your unreal
game is not going to support
the new awesome screen on the iphone or
it's not going to
integrate with this feature in the long
term yeah it means there's
your game's gonna die well that's a
that's a little that's a little silver
lining though
yeah there's definitely games that i
have that i will not uh
i i have an ipad that's like an old ipad
air or whatever that i will not update
because there's games that i know that
it will no longer support
because it forces them to go you know
lana with the
pt uh yeah you'll know that you got a
ps4 that goes
just sits over there and it's the same
way and i can't get that
i can't get that game ever again and i
would lose everything
so i mean it's it's 100 within apple's
like no keep
you can make whatever you want if you
want to keep it on our store
so question two then which is
way more just kind of
well i guess our word of the day
speculative um
is because this appears to be a
an epic as a company violate
term violation in their deal with apple
as concerns fortnite but which drags
uh unreal into the mess as a result
i'm wondering if the solution is a kind
of
like sort of in the spirit of like
cayman island tax shelters
if if unreal as an engine
if they were to divest that if they
split up
yeah like could could unreal and the
support of that be its own company
that is at least on paper not actually
part of epic anymore even though
presumably all the beneficiaries would
remain beneficiaries of that kind of
thing
because they are it's basically it's two
it's a company that makes two
very different pro well more than two
but like they have one massively
successful game and then
this other business that's that's you
know
freaking half the industry or more i
haven't so yeah that's that is stupid
that i need to bring up uh what does
notarize mean
notarized no to rise like when n o t
a r i z e i mean uh
notaries something like confirmation of
the validity of a document right
yeah well there are people that are
there i mean i can answer that
there are licensed notaries whose job
are to be the official witness to you
signing a document
and enter into a yeah it's a witness
signature essentially it's a witness
okay so the verge wrote epic won't be
able to notarize mac
apps either a process that can make
installing epic software more difficult
or block it all together oh that's a
different use
so notarizing so on so on the mac in
particular i can tell you that is you
can get a certificate you know when you
i don't know if any of you have any
bring canvas when you download a piece
of software and it comes that it says
uh when you try and open it says this
has been downloaded from the internet we
can't vouch for if it's secure
that you can get certified that's that
thing you always have hazardously click
yeah i'm sure it's fine
well i'm sure it's okay yeah exactly but
it's a thing and what's interesting is
all apps are notarized before they can
be run on newer versions of mac os even
if they're distributed outside the app
store so this would basically say the
same it just means that
at a certain point you would not be able
to install
any more epic games or sorry on real
games
even if they were running on all done
real because they aren't notarized
so i don't this is where this is where
we're at the edge of my knowledge
because i'm not an unreal developer
um my understanding would be that those
games
would not be notarized by default and
the developer of that game
could then notarize but i might be wrong
actually i don't that one i'm not sure
on
this is a very special episode but to be
fair basically everyone is being
speculative on this right now because we
don't know what we started talking about
we are not in the room
we're all very aware of that i was
setting the tone guys
i knew you were you were foreshadowed
let's talk about the bible now
let's speculate about business deals and
affairs between afghanistan
i was going to say i mean i think i
think uh they affected
the same number of people so it's a set
up it's what family guys like how is
this going to pertain to any epi
rest of the episodes
i mean it's purely selfishly this is one
of those where the first thing that i
read is i wonder
if this is going to impact me in terms
of um
the pathless because the pathways impact
me
yeah pretty much 2020. as we established
all future episodes are going to be
about me
yeah so to that answer it's time to talk
about sane garris
uh i'm just taking right there this is a
twitter reference for everyone who
doesn't follow us on twitter we had a
conversation on twitter about rex
uh but back to the pathless what what is
your what is your question well because
because pathless is developed and unreal
yeah
and um and it was
uh the apple arcade has leaned heavily
on it as this is an apple arcade title
it will be available on ios devices but
it will also be shipping on ps4 ps5
day one and it's an epic store uh
exclusive
so it's like it's basically got it's
basically that scene in full throttle
where the motorcycle is absolutely
getting a quarter
quarter uh in different directions like
so i i i mean you know
this is
this is me being it's always fun when
the story like this comes out in public
so that everyone sees how ridiculous all
of this side of the industry actually is
worth saying oh wait wait wait wait i
just have to be very mike
in for a moment and just full disclosure
i am
not speaking on behalf of giant squid or
annapurna here
i don't know the ramifications i didn't
have a chance to ask them
i just know that on the face of it that
game is basically
standing on either side of a split down
an iceberg
and uh and so yeah it just made me feel
anxious
it's worth saying just to add to that is
this is where the fact that the games
industry is people rather than just a
bunch of contracts is important is i'm
sure
a lot of people involved in a situation
like that are talking to each other and
figuring it out
and and the contractual side of this is
messy obviously for lots of reasons but
there's also
you know people who will be having calls
and having conversations and figuring
out parts
of that man
it's messy and like then also that like
fortnight tried to
activate uh their fans by like promoting
a hashtag in game
saying free fortnight like it's the
whole thing is just so cyberpunky to me
like this is two mega corporations
trying to fight like including on social
media
and get engagement and just it's just so
wild to watch
so wait i have another question okay um
i'm just going to go
troy angry birds does that mean that you
never
played strategy
i said troy does that mean that you
never really got into rts's because
that's such a pc
genre i'm just taking this back forty
five twelve pcc
i remember the first time that my dad
ever pulled out a box
with four letters on it and small little
pieces
called risk and i was like okay
and so teaching me the tenements of what
i mean i'll
command and conquer and all that to be
clear i was just being snarky but i'm
loving this answer
oh that'll teach you well because i got
a lot of childhood
father-son risk also so you you jumped
into
fathers and sons of well parents and and
children has been a theme
of this dude this is this is stupid i i
there's so guys you don't understand
my parents played my i i come from
in the same way that allah like you come
from you're a generational writer i'm a
generational
gamer because my parents instead of
watching tv or whatever
they would go into the computer room and
they would put in a disk drive that had
multiple like five but they wouldn't let
little troy play a game on the computer
you said you'd never play
computers playing on the computer
[Music]
what's a leisure suit larry dad can i
see go to bed son
[Music]
the uh nice austin there it is oh austin
was about to play
hello tune they were playing a game
called zork
and they were into it and they had this
notepad
and they were i mean this is what they
did they were they were like cracking
i mean geraldo rivera unlocking troy i
can just picture the scene as troy
eating cereal at 11 o'clock at night in
a dimly lit room
my own dinner you can see the glow down
the hall from the computer room
cheese sticks [ __ ] oliver twist
exactly sir
so anyway they get to a point in the
game where they realize
oh no they're in hell
and it's like they had like this crisis
of conscience like
i guess we can't play this and so
there's a whole like generation of games
that if there was
if it skewed at all metaphysical
spiritual demonic quote-unquote anything
like that
i couldn't i couldn't participate in it
i couldn't i couldn't listen to it
and there was this constant
juxtaposition so my
what i was able to parse out from this
culture
was very very narrow um so there's a lot
of stuff that i i missed out on
and and had to come back much later
that's why
there's there's a lot of people of my
generation or or even younger
that are super cut they're console
gamers i was an arcade gamer
so i mean like my my respite was my
parents wouldn't buy me a nintendo or
buy me a sega i had to go to all my
friends houses and play on theirs
i was the
your whole career is just one giant i'll
show you
it was the financial investors my
parents
yeah my parents didn't have the 100 100
quid 200 quid whatever to
to to why are your parents using quidd
troy
she established that earlier
what they did have was a need to go out
on a saturday
without their 10 year old son and and
they could pay five bucks
for a babysitter in the in the shape of
arcade tokens which is just bananas to
me to think it's like here you go go to
the arcade we'll be back in
several hours if you don't get kidnapped
that happened to me too
one of the um as a as a apropos barely
of that
uh when i worked a few years ago with
the tripod boys down in melbourne
um on this comedy
show called this gaming life um there's
a whole song in there
where he talks about growing up and
dealing with childhood bullies where his
parents are like you need a hobby we're
going to enroll you in
in sports and he says the kids weren't
playing sports all they ever did was
pull down each other's pants
and just screw with each other basically
like childhood
bullies you know yeah so the whole song
is like that's the chorus pulling down
each other's pants and it's like this
whole recurring thing
and then he goes one day i rebelled i
took money out of my
uh my mom's purse when she wasn't
looking and i went down to the arcade
because at the arcade
everyone wears belts and it's like that
was the origin point of me as a gamer
yeah it's
so freaking hilarious yeah they are they
are fantastic i should leave a link to
where you can
find tripod they're so good um all right
we got we gotta wrap this up but i i
didn't want to say like this topic is
just like so monolithic and it's going
to keep developing
monolith is actually a different
developer [ __ ] sake
[Laughter]
in the upper quadrant on my screen there
just just real quick the last thing that
i wanted to
note was that jesus christ basically
epic filed for
preliminary injunction against apple
asking the court to stop the company
from cutting it off
epic says it will be irreparably harmed
long before final judgment comes if it
does not obtain
the injunction and then apple basically
responded by saying
that epic the unfortunate step of
violating the app store guidelines and
that it would be making
it would make every effort to work with
epic to resolve these violations so
it seems like that's what dicks always
say will try to resolve it but they said
resolve not change they they are trying
to make epic resolve their violation so
i don't know that's the crucial thing is
epic's entire point is that the rules
they're being held to
aren't fair awful and illegal yes which
is well
illegal i presume like i think i think
that's their case whether or not it's
true
whatever but like that's their case and
that's that's what they're gonna have to
spend years proving isn't it interesting
to think that
massive ramifications this this i i
picture like two people
one on behalf of apple one on behalf of
epic sitting at a conference table
like the old apple pc uh commercial
exactly yeah
justin long and yeah what are we gonna
do
here guys who's the other
yeah i think those were great ads um
i um they really were they worked they
were hilarious they really
spoke to the the anyway so i to me the
thing that's fascinating is picturing
that these two could be sitting across
from the table and it's like
whoever signs whatever piece of document
it's like a multi-billion dollar
signature yeah and just the notion of
so much funneling down to such a and
will impact
years said
this this 30 would seemingly i mean i i
don't think it was
that figure came to haphazardly but it's
kind of an arbitrary number
was decided 20 years ago in a separate
it's a seriously important number it's a
very like every games
every games company gives thirty percent
of the money their games make to the
platform those games are sold on at
least it's protection money
you understand you pay me
like that goes down by 18 that's
that's a big oh yeah that's a big change
to every games company and that's
you know massive i feel like i don't
totally get that
we'll see yeah that's why it's such a
shame that there's such a
pervasive gamer we'll say skepticism
charitably about the epic store because
if
if if half can i feel like i want to
look into it i don't know
entirely where that comes yeah
numbers still dramatically outpace epic
stores
numbers so even if they if it's not
about hating
the epic store it still hasn't been
bought onto but just think about
the seismic financial shift if even a
quarter
or half of steem's user base shifted to
the epic store
and that percentage different was
suddenly now going
to developers like think of the
just the huge financial change that that
would mean
for oh yeah
yeah it's hard to imagine that it not a
new camera new webcam for me
just yeah
um all right i have no [ __ ] idea how
i'm going to title this disaster of an
episode
um austin do you want to play us
[Music]
play watch listen is brought to you by
alana pierce and twizzlers
that's right twizzlers the candy that
sticks in your teeth as much as your gut
tune in next week for another exciting
episode of
play watch listen you went longer than i
was expecting